-I know that you're close
to Blake Shelton.
-Oh, yes.
-Obviously, he's on "The Voice."
Did you reach out to him
for advice?
Did you say,
"should I go do -- "
-Sadly, I did.
-Yeah.
-I don't know why.
-Yeah, that's weird.
-I would recommend to never
reach out to him.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-No, he was -- when he heard --
it's funny, I think Blake knew
about me, you know, 'cause
Blake's, you know, he's in TV.
He hears all the whispers,
but --
-Oh, yeah. He's showbiz.
-I think he knew about me --
-He -- yeah, Mr. Showbiz.
Mr. Sexiest Man Alive
and all that.
[ Laughter ]
-How did that go over in
the country community
when Blake
was Sexiest Man Alive?
-We were quite perplexed.
-Yeah.
-But we got over it.
[ Laughter ]
-Sure, yeah.
-No, we --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-No, he is a beautiful man.
-Yes, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. From a distance.
-Yeah.
-And --
[ Laughter ]
-When he's here, we make him
sit all the way at the end.
Yeah.
-Yeah, you, like, move
the couch. Oh, that's anchored!
Yeah, you're not moving
that thing.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, Blake did call me
and, man, he was
really excited for me because,
you know, in the country world,
man, we -- like, I love touring.
I love getting on the bus,
rolling down the road,
hanging with my buds,
going and playing shows.
And Blake was excited
because he -- he wanted to see
my reaction
to this whole other segment.
-Right.
-I mean, TV has its own --
you know, TV has its
own little lane and even --
even when, you know,
we were rolling into the city
yesterday and there's a big
billboard, "American Idol."
And here's this --
this yahoo right here,
and I'm like, "Whoo, all right,
it's about to get interesting."
But Blake was really excited
for me
because he knew it was something
that I would enjoy, and I have.
It's been -- when I'm on set,
you know, it's been
10, 12-hour days,
but it's fun in this role.
I'm enjoying.
-You have something else
really exciting coming up.
I know you're still
going on tour
which is really exciting and
you're playing some stadiums.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Some baseball stadiums.
Dodger Stadium.
-Dodger Stadium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First, is this true?
The first country music show
ever at Dodger Stadium.
-First country show ever at
Dodger Stadium,
and we're doing -- we're putting
dates up for Fenway.
-Oh, that's exciting.
[ Cheers ]
-And Wrigley. I was almost
scared that I hadn't announced
all my venues, so I wanted to
keep it secret, but just...
-[ Laughs ]
-You know,
but it's been amazing.
We got Sam Hunt out with us.
-That's great.
-And Jon Pardi and, uh...
[ Cheers ]
So it's going to be --
it's going to be a fun summer.
A lot of fun tailgating
and country music
at Dodger Stadium!
It's going to be a first.
-Country music
at Dodger Stadium. Your album is
about how country you are.
-Yes.
-Is there something --
is there anything you left out?
-On the song --
-Yeah.
-"What makes you country?"
-Yeah, 'cause, I mean, it tells
a lot of what makes you country?
-Let me see, um, you know, we
have multiple pigs on the farm.
-Yeah. That's good.
That makes you country.
-That's quite important.
-Yeah.
-I have a farm truck that's
used just for the farm.
-Okay.
-It doesn't even have
a license plate.
-Oh, wow.
-So you're not allowed
to even drive it on --
-You can't take it out
on the road.
-On pavement.
-Yeah.
-And lastly, yeah. I have hired
a full-time bass fishing --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, have a guy that --
I have this bass lake and his
job is to grow the bass to --
The biggest bass in the world.
-Wow! And he's full time?
-Full time.
-What does...So what does he do?
Does he kind of just go around
with a plate on a boat
and just --
-He hand feeds them.
-He hand feeds the bass.
-You know, he gives them
massages so they can...swim.
[ Laughter ]
-He has a bass spa.
-So they can swim --
yeah, the bass spa.
-Gotcha. Now are these --
do these bass get so fat
that they're easier to catch?
-Yeah, then they're so --
they're so portly, they don't
really swim well.
-Yeah. Do you have to even throw
a hook or do you just reach in?
-So, they're just, like, you
hook them and they're just like,
"Ahh, I'm tired!"
-[ Laughs ] -"Just end this."
-"It's stressful being
in your pond!"
-That's pretty country. Yeah.
To have a full time bass guy
is pretty country.
-See, they're all --
we release them, though, so it's
not like we're growing them for,
like, some weird high-grade
sushi, bass sushi.
-Gotcha.
So you just catch them --
-So I people come --
yeah, we just catch them and --
-And you throw 'em back.
-Yeah, so they're -- yeah,
they're like our -- they're like
our little pets, you know.
-That's really nice. Yeah.
-But, you know, the boys
get out there and, you know,
we've spent a lot of time
growing these fish.
We're trying to catch, like --
Anyway, it requires a lot
of time, I've learned.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's why you need
a bass guy.
-And my boys -- my boys will run
up to the back porch
and they're like,
"Dad, I caught this."
And I'm like,
"Son, get back to the pond..."
[ Laughter ]
"And get the fish back
in the lake.
His eyes are drying out.
Get him back in there." So --
-All right. All right.
Well, every part of that is more
country than any interaction
I've had with my son.
-I would hope so.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Thank you so much --
-But we catch you up
with your son.
-All right, thank you very much.
Thanks for sticking around
and doing a song.
-Yeah.
-I can't wait.